[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the 21st annual Victor
Polestar Memorial Lecture as you know we
have had these lectures for over two
decades in these departments in honor of
Victor star who was a faculty in our
department actually was the Department
of meteorology when he was there
and this broad-ranging topics in
atmospheric sciences so we're very
pleased to have today the first such
lecture in that most very chemistry and
particularly please it's professor Paul
Cruz and was giving the presentation
today Paul is a close colleague and
friend of mine I think it's very fitting
that he will give us this first most
very chemistry lecture because all this
is really or started as a meteorologist
but eventually he saw the light and
became a chemist as well so let me tell
you a few things about he was born in
Amsterdam in the Netherlands and he
started first in fact his first jobs
were as an engineer in the bridge
construction Bureau of the city of
Amsterdam then eventually he moved to
Sweden and where he was working at the
house construction Bureau what
eventually he got a PhD in meteorology
at the University of Stockholm in Sweden
I think he started there the job as a
computer program but switched to
meteorology in 1974 between 1974 and
1980 he came to the United States he was
director of the air quality division at
anchor I think we call it the
atmospheric chemistry division at the
National Center for Atmospheric Research
and in 1980 he went back to Europe to
Germany he has been there until now as a
director of the atmospheric chemistry
division of the Max Planck Institute
working me in mind at the same time he
has been and he's still a part-time
professor at the Scripps Institution of
Oceanography in San Diego as well as in
Utrecht University in the Netherlands
now Paul has many honors and awards
several pages which I would take the
time to read what I thought I select
just a handful with a certain bias as
you'll see one of them is he said a GU
fellow he got he became a fellow of the
American Geophysical Union in 1986
I just became a fellow myself just a
year or two ago in 1989 he got a Tyler
price for the environment
happens to be a price I've also received
at some point in time another very
interesting prize is the recipient of
the Max Planck fortunes price which is a
program that is giving to a German
investigator in collaboration to an
American scientist so I was fortunate to
receive that with with Paul in fact it
was a very productive price because we
got funding to do research and with us a
wonderful student Thomas hoop with who
was a whole student to begin with and
became my student afterwards and then in
1995 for receive the Nobel Prize in
Chemistry and of course I had the honor
of sharing it with him and with sherry
Rowland so these are the only prizes I
will mention let me do one additional
thing I want to read you the title of
his PhD thesis in 1968
we got at the University of Turku and it
is the termination of parameters
appearing in the dry and the wet
photochemical theories of also in the
stratosphere so that was in 1968 so this
really brings me to explain to you that
Paul did this groundbreaking work in
understanding how the stratosphere
functions how the chemistry of the
stratosphere works really discovering
the catalytic cycles the nature of these
cycles is very important in explaining
how is it that tray species in this case
nitrogen oxides or hydrogen oxides very
small amounts of certain catalysts can
have this very large effect on in
controlling the abundance of ozone in
the stratosphere and also install called
reportar the second thesis I think it's
a doctorate in science this is this was
in 1973 and the title is on the
photochemistry of ozone in the
stratosphere and troposphere and
pollution of the stratosphere by
high-flying aircraft so this is another
milestone Paul was really the first one
to recognize that human activities could
impact also in the stratosphere which is
this major natural system that it's
truly a global issue so that all goes
back to his early days in Sweden since
then he has made numerous contributions
both to stratospheric chemistry as well
as to troposphere chemistry again too
many for me to list but he will talk to
us today about the troposphere chemistry
the title of this presentation is the
major role of the tropics in atmospheric
chemistry the need for strong research
efforts
if you Paul Crutzen
[Applause]
well thank you for this introduction now
you took ten minutes of my talk I have
to shorten it down I guess because
everybody wants to go to to the drinks
afterwards
good well it's nice to be here and in
fact to have such an audience so late in
the evening because normally this time I
go to bed well here we have my lecture
will not be really full for the expert
so the experts who this will be a little
bit of fundamental lecture on how the
chemistry of the atmosphere work so if
the experts already know that and and
they know it they can leave but you're
also allowed to stay if we look at the
distribution of ozone in the atmosphere
and we all know that it's almost
everything is in the stratosphere and
about the stratosphere I do not speak
very much in this lecture there's very
little ozone in the troposphere at most
about 10% of all atmospheric ozone is
located in the troposphere and for a
long time it was thought that that ozone
was not very interesting some
meteorologists have been looking at it
it was normally believed that ozone
would come down from the stratosphere
into the troposphere and would be
destroyed at the surface this was
basically the belief say around 1970
when all this and it's in fact ozone is
of course coming down from the
stratosphere in the troposphere this
this is the picture which was prevalent
in the early days
ozone was produced in the stratosphere
and a very small fraction of it actually
the flux of ozone from the stratosphere
into the troposphere is less than 1% or
all I was on formed in the stratosphere
so a little small leakage will bring
ozone into this into the troposphere but
it was believed for a very long time
that that was the whole story that it
was don't then destroy it at the ground
and that this happens is also sometimes
very clearly observed here we have a
so-called intrusion of material from the
stratosphere into the troposphere we see
here izo lines of radioactive species
which in the 50s was produced completely
in the stratosphere by bomb testing we
see ozone and we see something and
meteorologically stable or almost inert
capacity namely the potential vorticity
and you see all these isin lines going
into the troposphere and part of this
ozone which follows that is then also
staying in the troposphere so the
picture looked extremely clear and in
fact very little interest was devoted to
ozone in the troposphere until roughly
the middle of the 70s we all know how
important ozone is the stratospheric
ozone filters out basically all
radiation between 240 and 300 nanometer
from which is coming down on the Earth
from the Sun however this it's not
perfect
around 300 nanometer UV radiation comes
down to the Earth's surface very much
dependent on the amount of ozone in the
stratosphere and this radiation is
harmful to much of it we all know it in
summertime sunburns
too much of it is not very good for you
so that is normally the UV radiation is
considered to be a negative factor also
ozone in the troposphere is considered
to be negative it's it harms people
lungs and lungs can be damaged and and
so on so and plant life can be damaged
by too much ozone in the troposphere
however it turns out that this ozone in
the troposphere has also very important
let's call it positive consequences and
one of the reasons is that the and it
goes back to some simple reactions here
ozone for Thomas's at wavelength below
there are nowadays we say almost 400
nanometer below in this wavelength
region produces all atoms in an
electronically excited state Oh singer D
which then has enough energy to react
that water vapor to make hydroxyl
radicals and these hydroxyl radicals
which play enormously important role in
keeping the atmosphere clean because the
hydroxyl radicals react with almost all
species which are produced by nature or
by mankind and deposited in the
atmosphere so here we summarize the two
reactions again by the way you see here
that because of these two reactions
ozone is destroyed we come back to that
to the budget of ozone in the
troposphere and we see here a number of
species which react with o age like
methane methane reacts rather slowly
with the hydroxyl radical and that's it
has a lifetime on average around the
world of about eight years and that
means that methane is found both in
northern and in the southern hemisphere
although almost all ozone also all
methane is produced in in the northern
hemisphere so but we go to other species
like ethane reacts much faster with our
age
and we see definitely much more in the
northern hemisphere and in the southern
hemisphere we go to a propane lifetime
of a few years a few days 10 days and we
hardly find anything of that in the
southern hemisphere and of course
isoprene which is emitted by the city at
for the city's forests has such a short
lifetime or orders of hours that we only
find this compound close to the forest
regions we have a number of sulfur
chlorine and many other gases which are
removed from the atmosphere by reaction
with our age and this was a major
discovery which goes back to 1971 which
a cheap levy who worked and here at the
Smithsonian Institute in just down the
river almost before this paper before
this knowledge it was simply not known
how compounds which go into the
atmosphere how they are removed and I
show you later some funny estimates
about budgets of trace gases which were
produced in at that time before that
time before because they they were far
out from reality now in the lowest
figures the lowest two figures here I
sort of summarize the good and the bad
of UV radiation here we have the
positive factor if we multiply the choir
the efficiency with which our single D
atoms are produced by ultraviolet
radiation multiplied it with the flux of
ultraviolet radiation down to the earth
surface which is a strong function of
our zone going down to it's shorter
wavelength we get curves which look like
this dependent on the amount of ozone in
the stratosphere that's the positive
part and but if you look at the DNA
damage we get a curve which looks very
similar so you cannot
that UV radiation is only damaging it
has positive it has negative science in
the 70s was also realized that ozone in
the troposphere was not inert of course
we saw already one reaction which in
which ozone is destroyed the effort
Allah sees and by ultraviolet radiation
but also reactions were discovered in
which ozone is either produced or
destroyed and the simplest set of
reactions which do the job we can
exemplify here by the oxidation of
carbon monoxide it starts by reaction
with o H that's how most stuff is
removed from the atmosphere H atoms are
formed in co2 co2 adds to the H atom H
o2 is formed and then depending on
whether there is enough and all in the
atmosphere HR to react with or NO to
make our agent no.2 or
in another cycle h r2 can react with
ozone to make our age and 202 if you go
to this side called the no.2 which is
formed here
it's very quickly dissociated in an O
and o atoms and the atoms recombine with
all its oxygen to make ozone the net
result of these reactions are that Co is
oxidized with two oxygen molecules into
co2 and ozone if there is too little air
now and the atmosphere then instead co
is oxidized to co2 but always on is
consumed and much depends on the amount
and now in the atmosphere when the ozone
is produced or destroyed so basically
the borderline is defined by the ratio
between an O and ozone and the rate
constants for various reactions enter
into this one can generally say that for
n no mixing ratios somewhere greater
than 10 to the minus 11 in the
atmosphere always on this produce
otherwise it can be destroyed it's
interesting to look at these reactions
we
in these photochemical reactions we can
consider carbon monoxide as a fuel it's
a low temperature combustion of carbon
monoxide we are really looking at which
is sort of incinerated by the presence
of photons in the atmosphere Co is the
fuel and we see also that we have lots
of catalysts being active in the
production or the destruction of ozone o
HH o - a no and no2 they all act as
catalysts in these reactions now this
this is the simplest set of reactions
which ozone is formed photochemically
and so smoke type reactions the next
simplest case if methane oxidation which
you see already many more reactions
entering into the scheme and but also
methane is everywhere like carbon
monoxide and if there's just enough and
on the atmosphere then ozone is formed
and of course if we go to more complex
molecule looks like isoprene we get
about thousand reactions to consider and
just if there is not an only atmosphere
always on is formed in the same way as
during the oxidation of carbon monoxide
now in always increasing in the
atmosphere and especially because
because of emissions at mid-latitudes
and also in the tropics by biomass
burning about which I will speak much
more little later in talk with increased
emissions of noe atmosphere especially
in industrial regions and also
increasing concentrations of say for
instance methane in the atmosphere one
of the fuels and also carbon monoxide
one would expect that ozone should have
gone up and this is indeed observed
there are for instance records of ozone
ground-level ozone going back to the end
of the last
tree in suburb of Paris Matsui and if
these are data which have been checked
by dieter clientís colleagues and seem
to indicate good quality measurements of
ozone at that time at that time about 10
am Ultimo were the average and also
concentrations which were measured and
nowadays in environments like this
there's just much more also about a
factor of two or three higher also in
the 20s and 30s optical measurements
were performed very often in the year
our presence in in Europe and the
typical concentrations for mixing ratios
which were measured at that time were of
the order of say 20 normal kamal and
what is measured typically nowadays is
about two times more even three times
more and also at station in southern
germany home ice and back we see in the
troposphere a substantial increase from
data taken in 1968 these are the annual
averages and in 1989 those twenty years
progress in always-on formation here
this increase in Ozone seems to have
stopped at the home Eisenberg station
you see that in the later years things
have leveled off maybe it is even a
slight decrease this may have to do with
the fact that nitrogen oxides are being
regulated in Europe so that the maximum
in ozone in whole paisa back may have
been reached so by the end of the 80s of
course it's also possible that some
meteorological factors have played a
role in this curve you have to further
analyze that now also models can be
developed and
when that is done the simplest model we
developed in minds about ten years ago
there are much more advanced models now
being used but I think still the
principles of what is happening can be
explained with the simple model we
developed also initially with the help
of wretching annual a model of transport
of chemistry and chemistry in in the
atmosphere we basically divide up the
earth in longitude and latitude blocks
and height blocks and then take
meteorological observations monthly mean
wind speeds and also a fudge factor the
eddy diffusion coefficients were
introduced and if you don't add
chemistry to the model in this case
carbon monoxide methane chemistry then
one can and also boundary at the ground
boundary layer values of carbon monoxide
and methane then one can start playing
games what one has to consider is that
and always put into the atmosphere by
lightning that's the same let's say
between industrial and pre-industrial
times but for industrial times of course
we have lots of inputs of nitrogen
oxides in the industrial world and this
is then also assigned to the model and
then even calculates how much ozone this
model then produces one gets in the case
of the pre-industrial atmosphere and
this is for the summer in July
pre-industrial atmosphere you see a
picture which well it's bluish almost
everywhere with a few exceptions roughly
of the order of 10 10 15 parts per
billion or none amount mole
near the other surface for the July case
you compare that with the present
situation and you get a much more
colorful figure you see you get much
enhanced ozone concentrations downwind
of the main pollution sources so an
increase by roughly effect of two or
three there compared to pre-industrial
situation so the model search basically
showed the same as the observations if
one looks at the budget of ozone in the
troposphere we have a number of
reactions in which ozone is formed ho2 +
mo + CH 3 o2 + mo are the reactions in
the carbon monoxide methane oxidation
schemes anytime these reactions take
place basically an ozone molecule is
formed and you see here under global you
see two numbers one of these numbers
expresses the the amount of ozone
produced in the troposphere globally in
units of 10 to the 12 mol per year and
the left number is calculated for the
present atmosphere and the right number
is calculated for the pre-industrial
atmosphere and you see the ozone forming
reactions you see also singlet D + water
vapour which is a loss reaction for
ozone there is some reaction of ozone
with ho2 and partially with Oh H is
coming in here if you look at the
chemical terms which show which are
shown here you see that the chemical
terms for certainly for the industrial
atmosphere are much larger than the flux
of ozone downwards from the stratosphere
and also large and then the destruction
of ozone at the ground this clearly
shows that ozone is formed and destroyed
in the troposphere in amounts which are
larger than the influx from the
and interestingly this was also true
today already for the pre-industrial
atmosphere although the emissions of Nov
smaller still the chemical terms were
were most more important than the flux
from the stratosphere so the internal
budget of ozone in the troposphere is
regulated by in situ chemical processes
and this is of course a big change from
the initial belief that ozone would be a
rush or rather inert gases in the
atmosphere in the troposphere these are
very important to point out that these
reactions which produce and destroy
ozone would never start if there would
not be some influx from the strategy
into the troposphere we have here an
auto catalytic system in which you need
some flux of ozone to get it started but
then you actually produce internally
much more or destroying much more than
the initial flux also we did some
analysis of this if you look at the
ozone in the atmosphere although the
internal cycle is so important still for
the total amount of ozone in the
troposphere the stratospheric part is of
large importance in the upper part of
the troposphere most of the ozone you
find there is still has an origin from
the stratosphere and that's a part which
is important for climate studies now I'm
getting to the tropics before that
briefly show you this figure this is
basically the distribution of ozone
total ozone as a function of latitude
and time of the year it's only average
values and what it shows is basically
this was by the very figure which was
made before the ozone hole develops on
this
a classic figure but in general or what
we see in this figure is that in the
tropics this is basically always some
sort of an ozone hole natural I was on
how minimum amount of total ozone is in
the tropics which has to do with the
height of the tropopause which is much
higher 18 kilometers in the tropics that
in the Sun in at high latitudes so most
ultraviolet radiation by far most
ultraviolet radiation comes down to the
Earth's surface
in the tropics and in the tropics you
find also in general maximum in water
vapour concentration so you would expect
the highest production of our wage and
the highest our wage concentrations in
the tropics and although we have very
few measurements to confirm that we have
to real if you rely on the model
calculation we see this clearly here is
depicted the concentration of our H
radicals in the troposphere as a
function of latitude southern hemisphere
northern hemisphere here and then also
height and in units of 10 to the 6
molecules per cubic centimeter so we
have a maximum here that means that many
gases which have lifetimes say of the
order of a few months or more are mainly
destroyed in the tropics examples of
such gases are carbon monoxide here also
the destruction rates depicted as a
function of latitude and methane so this
is where where the OAH radical is the
most active and most of the cleaning of
the atmosphere is taking place the
calculations which with which these
results were yeah these calculations can
be checked
and we had early we had a wonderful
chemical product which was measured by
around the world for instance by by Ron
Prinn and his colleagues and what is
shown here is metal core for methyl
chloroform his compound which basically
is only produced by the chemical
industry and this mainly destroyed by
reaction with OAH in the atmosphere and
one can compare at various stations
around the world the calculated and
observed mixing ratios of methyl
chloroform in the atmosphere and if you
look at these curves you can hardly
distinguish them this model as it was
developed about ten years ago gave
roughly the the right result so the H
concentration cross section which I
showed you before cannot be too far off
from reality this is very interesting
because I repeat this now here basically
the curve which curves I had in color
indicating the breakdown of carbon
monoxide by reaction with our age and
methane by reaction with our age in the
industrial atmosphere this this figure
and you can do the same game in the
pre-industrial atmosphere and you can
say that this represents the destruction
of methane carbon monoxide must have
caught be balanced by an input into the
atmosphere so you can say that the
natural sources for carbon monoxide and
methane are given by this low figure
here and of of the pre end of the
industrial atmospheres are given here so
here with the natural sources here we
have the sum of natural plus
anthropogenic sources the difference is
the anthropogenic source so you can use
this sort of model calculations to
derive budget of ozone of methane in the
atmosphere and what one finds then is
that a present of the order of 630
million tonne of methane
is used in the current atmosphere in the
pre-industrial the natural source of
methane is of the order of 270 and the
difference is say 360 so what this
basically shows is that an input by
human activities of methane in the
atmosphere is probably somewhat larger
than the natural source of methane in
the atmosphere the anthropogenic sources
of methane in the atmosphere are given
here the individual amounts are still
rather uncertain in many cases but at
least we know roughly what the some of
these sources should be and you see here
animals play a large role anaerobic
fermentation is a large source from
methane in the atmosphere so ruminants
and animal based oxidation or
fermentation is a large source for
methane in the atmosphere via rice
fields biomass burning landfills and
natural gas and oil industry leaks it's
interesting to see how important the
animal side and I don't know whether you
ever thought about it but say a typical
family of five people is owns 1.4 1.1
fourth of a cow so somewhere in the
world there are lots of cows supplying
us here with cheese and meat and so on
and because we have others here's of the
order of 10 chickens just supplying us
with meat
it shows that what I showed you before
us already an indication strong
indication how important the tropics are
in all of this to give you an idea about
the the fundamental step forward which
was made by the discovery how important
hydroxyl radicals are in cleaning the
atmosphere I give you in this viewgraph
some so-called authoritative estimate of
budget estimates of methane carbon
monoxide in the atmosphere in 1968 or
such an analysis published and it
claimed that the methane source from
natural wetlands would be of the order
of 1180 million tonne of methane here we
know now that the real number is of the
order 270 at that time we think simply
was no knowledge at all available about
how things were removed from the
atmosphere Antipas Jenica missions they
were rather close to each other if you
look at the CEO budget you see here
number 75 in 1968 and we know now that
the number here for the natural source
is more like 860 and the anthropogenic
source was also they strongly
underestimated at that time good many
some of you may think that the tropics
in the southern hemisphere are still
clean regions of the atmosphere it's
very little industry you might think
that there is a very important human
activity already taking place in the
tropics and that is biomass burning
whoever has been in the tropics during
the dry season no knows how polluted the
atmosphere can be and here we have some
estimates of the amount of carbon which
is burned in the tropics by various
activities having to do in many cases
with rather primitive agriculture the
shifting target
agriculture it is
estimated that between thousand and two
thousand million tonne of carbon is
burnt each year in this activity
permanent deforestation 500 to 1400
savanna fires fourth hundred to two
thousand firewood burning is better
known 300 to 600 and agricultural waste
burning say four 500 to 800 see these
numbers are very uncertain but they add
up to roughly about 2 3 to 7 times 10 to
the 15 gram of carbon per year this is a
very large amount of biomass which is
burnt in the Tropic each year and this
is the dirty burning I mean it's a lot
of pollutants are coming into the
atmosphere so this is a actually this is
what is exposed to the fire this is what
actually is burned between try 2 and 5
times 10 10 to the 15 gram of carbon per
year and that stuff in that burning
stuff gets into the atmosphere and
basically all the molecules we know
which are contributing to photochemical
smog at in our part of the world
also I emitted burn biomass burning in
the atmosphere we in mines we have set
up a little Bora Torre in which we can
burn materials from different parts of
the world and then look at the emissions
from these materials and we find typical
typically here we have the temperature
of the fires we have the flaming face
and smoldering face here and together
depending on whether beyond the flaming
face or the smuggling face of the fires
we get different kinds of pollutants in
the atmosphere by carbon dioxide carbon
monoxide methane and many other
hydrocarbons methyl chloride and so on
so the rich menu of compounds are
released into the atmosphere by biomass
burning in the tropics this is clearly
affecting
the level of pollution gases or
background gases in the tropics and not
only gases but also soot and smoke
particles here we have data from Kuya
Valles is a station in mato grosso in
Brazil and you see maximum
concentrations of aerosol in the
atmosphere coinciding with the time when
biomass burning is taking place in
Brazil now this biomass burning produces
as I said the same compounds which
basically also lead to photochemical
smoke in our part of the world but
there's one big difference in the
tropics this is a rural phenomenon in
our part of the world is mainly a urban
phenomena so this is covering much
larger areas and we see the results of
that very clearly again from this
station in mato grosso in the year 1988
in the month of September for about half
of the time half of the days in the
month of September the ozone levels 80
ppb of ozone was exceeded during the
month of September the time of biomass
burning in Brazil now this is different
from years year to year some years it's
just very bad are the years it may be
better this depends on meteorological
conditions and it's not only happening
in in the in Brazil but also in say
Zimbabwe in South southern part of
Africa what you see here are profiles of
smoke particles of carbon monoxide
carbon dioxide and ozone which were
measured by a research team from our
Institute
on the Andy Andre you see these Maxima
in concentrations and these are the
result of biomass burning which doesn't
hasn't taken place here of course at
these altitudes at that time but had
happened somewhere else near the ground
and then the air was lifted to its high
altitudes where then the always almost
formed this phenomena must cannot only
been seen in situ it can also be seen
from space here we have data on the
amount of carbon monoxide in the
troposphere which were measured during
the wet season in the southern
hemisphere and the dry season in the
southern hemisphere the blue colors mean
very little Co relatively little Co the
red colors mean lots of Co in the
troposphere and you see that in October
there is more carbon monoxide in the
southern hemisphere then six months
earlier basically the dry season in the
northern hemisphere shows you that you
cannot consider the tropics and the
southern hemisphere is very clean and
this is also seen in the ozone
distribution figure which comes from a
Czech Fishman in the period September to
November you see that is this outflow
this production of ozone in the southern
hemisphere
affecting a large parts of the southern
hemisphere including Australian toast
mania here interestingly this model of
which I showed you some results before
simulates that see this tone of
relatively high ozone values extending
into the southern hemisphere
so it can there can be a lot of ozone in
the southern hemisphere but you can also
have circumstances in which you hardly
find any ozone in the southern
hemisphere and that is in regions where
basically you are far away from the
continents from the inputs of
anthropogenic and also natural
hydrocarbons and nitrogen oxides in the
atmosphere in 1993 we did measurements
this was an activity by the Center for
studies of climate and clouds at the at
the center at long description
Institution of Oceanography in
collaboration with the decline in in
Germany a cruise was made from Honiara 2
to Solomon Islands 2 to Christmas Island
and during this cruise balloons versa
were launched into the atmosphere and
ozone was measured and what was often
measured was ozone profiles which looked
like this close to the troca force
hardly any ozone it was common and also
in the lower troposphere there are the
low concentrations of ozone in the
troposphere this was expected but that
it could end up with such low ozone
values in the upper troposphere that was
new and it was not only measured on long
profile but it was measured at several
on several profiles several occasions
and this is shown in these panels you
see very often situations in which ozone
goes down to almost zero here here again
etc so it was a big surprise and I'm not
sure that we understand very well why
this is happening so if we consider the
enormous importance of the hydroxyl
radical in keeping the atmosphere clean
and we realize how important all zone is
as a precursor for high
rocks radicals and how the hydroxyl
radicals are mainly located in the
troposphere we must of course wonder
about the ozone distribution in the
troposphere
in the tropics we cannot say that this
distribution of ozone in the tropics is
a very regular distribution because it's
highly variable we can have situations
with very little ozone or we can have
situations which much more ozone
whenever we are under the influence of
biomass burning for instance so in order
to understand the atmospheric chemistry
we have to understand what is happening
in the tropics and we have to understand
the distribution of ozone in the tropics
and unfortunately if you look at the
stations where measurements in the
tropics are occasionally made they are
very few just part of you to set up a
good basis quantitative basis for our
studies so one of the the messages of my
talk is that we have to improve on that
situation very strongly I would like to
show you at the end a few most more
recent results I showed you before this
vigor which indicates the oxidation
schematically of isoprene in the
atmosphere isoprene is emitted from
tropical forests in large amounts in the
atmosphere and during its oxidation very
interesting chemical things happen these
were measured by us in the beginning of
last year we had an expedition in the in
Suriname this is the former Dutch Guiana
where we on an aircraft measured in situ
the distribution of isoprene and
products which are derived from isoprene
in the atmosphere with a new instrument
the proton transfer reaction mass
spectrometer and whenever we were in the
boundary layer
here we have the flight routes of plane
when everywhere in the flank boundary
layer we saw isoprene and B sword methyl
vinyl ketone and also an hydroxy
hydroperoxide of which derives from hawk
isoprene so they all there and the
effect the model which we developed gave
roughly the same results the Lagrangian
model fed by emissions of isoprene from
the forest gave about the amounts which
which were measured in fact was so much
isoprene was admitted in the atmosphere
that it titrated hydroxyl radicals to a
large degree so the average OAH
concentration averaged over 24 hours in
the boundary layer over the forest which
we calculated was only 2 times 10 to the
5 molecules per cubic centimeter the
very low amount for a tropical region we
saw other stuff fair in surprisingly
high concentrations one compound which
is of substantial importance is of
course carbon monoxide we saw but also
we saw acetone mixing ratios of the
order of two non am Ultimo even more and
acetone it turns out this is research of
the last five to ten or five years is an
important source for hydroxyl radicals
at high altitudes so it's definitely
formed in the tropics in the forest
regions in large amounts and we also saw
acetyl nitrile this is a product of
biomass burn in the tropics and
elsewhere of course finally some results
from a more recent campaign in the
tropics the index campaign which was
conducted last February March in the
Indian Ocean region with base in more in
the Maldives
during this
experiment which occupies some 150
scientists from all around the world
including India during this this
experiment many measurements were made
from ships from aircraft and also
ground-based the idea about this
experiment was to see whether the
pollution which is produced over the
Indian continent in general South and
Southeast Asia whether it could reach
the Indian Ocean region so we went out
there and we also went south of the ITCC
Intertropical Convergence zone and you
see a nice atmosphere not too dirty
rather clean but then mostly we were
south of the Intertropical Convergence
zone and there it looked like this it
was dirty over very large regions down
to the ITCZ
the Indian Ocean region was highly
polluted it was polluted to such an
extent that mostly what you see is the
particles that the optical depth of the
absorption optical depth of the
particles was of the order of could be
of the order of 0.4 so it's a there's a
lot of this is rather dark stuff which
was out there and the effect on the
radiation balance of a substantial
region over the Indian Ocean is
considerable some some estimates
indicate that under these conditions
only about only about 20% of the solar
radiation which normally should reach
the surface of the ocean didn't arrived
at was either absorbed in the atmosphere
or backscatter to space so this was a
rather shocking experience for us and
we were curious to find something we
were a little worried that maybe we
don't find anything because it's so far
away from the pollution source but that
we would find such a situation it was a
big surprise for everyone
everybody of us so that shows that you
know we have to start already now
worrying about what is happening in the
tropics and in the developing world in
the developed developing world I mean
this is where most of the action will be
in the future and we this is my pitch of
course I mean that's where much more
effort to go into this research we have
to find out what is happening in the
tropics and we have so few data at the
moment so I hope that with you support
and little propaganda we can do much
more of these kinds of experiments I
thank you for your attention and
hopefully I still allowed two different
questions
[Applause]
from India Southeast Asia and probably
also China it's a huge population behind
it to some 2000 million people yeah it's
good burning I think it's part of it but
there's also lots of dirty burning off
of data we have to find out what
actually what was that was they they it
all came from
but it contained a large amount of
absorbing aerosol it so it's different
from sulfate aerosol
which measurements Fox oh I I haven't
looked into that I mean the model when I
said the mobile agreed rather well with
what was observed this was for the
boundary layer you refer to the to the
the measurements in Suriname yeah oh I I
have not checked was not developing
mobile calculations for that
by burning map repair and yeah so is
there any evidence for I don't know I
mean we have to go out there I mean of
course the far fewer people leaving
Italy living in these other parts of the
world that's I think we should follow up
on this
the letter I am more worried about yes
that's the right word but on the other
hand of course it's also highly or
awfully interesting finding out more
about it but what does this all mean I
mean then you've been suddenly you 20%
of the solar radiation it's not
appearing at the Earth's surface and
must do something maybe not immediately
maybe be armed the process of building
up some something well for H I would not
trust the models I mean we roughly
understand in the right ballpark and I
mean we were very lucky when we got
these results and with additional
chemistry we have added to the model in
the meanwhile we actually get somewhat
different results which don't which
still look quite good but not so good as
indicated here so this it means that in
the current models which are more
advanced there's something missing which
we did not be discovered before when we
have much more simplified model so it's
sort of contradictory but it's the case
so what I mean
Rome can better answer this question
what is happening to our age there will
be you cannot say in general our age
will grow or decrease by so and so many
percent there will be parts of the world
the hydroxyl or increase wherever you
put more you know in the atmosphere and
the other parts of the world where it
will decrease because more carbon
monoxide is put into the atmosphere and
the global balance we I don't think our
models are by far not good enough to to
derive low balance I think we need
traces to to do that other means of
we do
yeah
or
we're in the air work and you know it's
very difficult yet resources to study
either problem one wanders away the
mission emerging in my magazine
well the the index solution I think was
not only biomass burning they can also
clean dirty coal burning and all of that
stuff behind it so we simply simply have
to find out but I mean what what will
happen in the future with big city
glommer it's only 30 million people
living there together how that will
change the overall chemistry of the
atmosphere this is a very important
question I mean if what is better to
spread out all this pollution of a large
area or put it all together in mainly a
big cities but what are you create
totally different say types of error so
for instance the coagulation cities is
so much stronger and so what the
developments of that would be I mean the
influence of cities on even on the
global scale is I think a very
interesting and the important issue
enjoy
try honey fried many I I mean if I would
guess now I probably of the order of 30
to 50 so they were mainly on one of the
ships the saga Konya and really some
quite a few of them we will do excellent
work so it's not a hopeless situation
but you of course you you raise a very
important point how do we get more of
these people in developing countries
into this game it's it's high technology
I mean you can educate people here but
do they go home to their country than to
do the research because there's it's
stay here because when they go home
there's nothing to do there that
governments are not interested but then
you sit at international negotiations
and there you see mostly the scientists
from the developing countries sitting in
the back rows and not saying much I mean
so they do not inform the their
government so you have this this
terrible vicious circle of things which
in some way we have to break but how is
it's not clear to me either
for supposedly that for it
the solution is non-linearity some you
sort of alluded to wonder the types of
requests and they're more efficiently
removed than maybe if you put them all
together in the smaller yeah so this I
think what is the the effect of
urbanization in the next century
especially on on atmospheric chemistry
is reason the interesting question as
it's positive and negative science well
I don't think at all about how young
kids will grow up in cities with thirty
million people that is a totally
different problem that this is social
you